every day you're on the Run you're
digging a hole that you may not be able
to get out of
[Music]
here am I running from the CIA
then why are they chasing you
most intense scenes to shoot when it
comes to a show like this is that the
card chases like what is it I think for
me the craziest one was I am thrown out
of a Blackhawk helicopter at some point
it's in the trailer so I'm not giving
too much away and that was not supposed
to be me the stunt guys in the morning
had done five or six takes and done a
great job and it was one of our ex-navy
seals who were lucky enough to have
Consultants from the CIA from the
military and he said it would be a lot
cooler if you did it and I said how
would that work and he said well how it
would work is if I just unbuckled your
seatbelt and threw you out right now and
he did right then and there on the show
his name's Kevin Kent and he should be
in jail
wait a minute so you weren't really
prepared for that not at all and you can
see it on my face when it when it
happens in the show yeah you're about to
cross the line and there may be no going
back because I'm trying to do the right
thing Wendell I see that you've been
performing Death of a Salesman on
Broadway and John's note to support you
what's it life having that support
Mike came too
uh it's been great I was I was nervous
you know I wanted to do great for them
you know I wanted to be on my game it's
an honor to do the play every night and
it makes it even more special when your
friends come it may be one of the most
proud I've ever been of someone I've
worked with in my life he's unbelievable
so if you haven't seen the show you have
to go see it
[Music]